what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Chucky season 2 episode 4 today John or
John how's it going Johnny Johnny
I'm good and bad how are you I'm doing
doing well thank you for asking me John
Humphrey anywho guys hey leave a like
that's what we ask right now the most
important thing you can do full length
watch along as we sync up with your own
copy for Chucky available for our super
sexy rejects over our patreon page thank
you to all who have joined us over there
so far your support means the world
helps keep the channel alive let's just
swing no action we gotta do this
foreign
times I want fresh baked chocolate chip
cookies with macadamia nuts in my
dressing room not walnuts you [ __ ]
walnuts give me hides this is third seat
of Chucky with them you could shove
those cookies straight up Chucky we're
live oh hello he has this to promote
Chucky goes psycho oh let's go into that
tone I like it we delve into family
secrets Hollywood sleeves and the
violent depraved acts of which the human
species is capable
All In The Name of Love
nice to see you too Mom
is that blood
it's corn syrup
it's your special day why don't you two
take a load off
yeah just get their coats
yeah they're gonna love that
are you two dating anyone yeah a guy
named Paul oh how nice and Glenn how
about you uh we're both dating Paul that
sounds complicated
you haven't left this house in over a
year there's a five inch layer of dust
over everything in your drinking has
gotten out of control Glenn when the
hell has gotten into you
we've been talking to Stan your
accountant he says you're running out of
money I'm doing fine
just like you two kids
mom who the hell is Nica Pierce
oh this is the
super horror comedy episode yep
taking on the bride through seed tone
yep
it's all fair game in this universe
and they also mentioned a Paul and a
Stan Eminem references
you installed a whole new security
system because you were worried that
some woman you barely knew was coming to
get you how many times have I told you
the cautionary tale of Judy Foster Jody
Foster
when I was little
did I ever hurt someone
yeah
oh there's some emotional repression
going on here there's a woman
she's blonde and she's
screaming because she's on fire
it just feels like I'm the one who did
it and
there's another voice that's a man and
he's nice he's
he's encouraging me
there must have been something I mean
some sort of trauma because I mean Glenn
and I
we've never felt
whole
all we want to know is why damn this is
an approach I wasn't expecting
[Music]
I hired a little extra help for
he was supposed to be here an hour ago
told you my improv class went late
you're a butler I didn't tonight I am
yes and honey all my shoes are in there
I don't want you stealing my Manola
blonics again
well he's dead
not everything has to be an unpleasant
surprise
[Music]
you wouldn't want to have people over
giving your Norma Desmond Vibes as of
late but isn't it nice to see everybody
I mean Auntie Gina
it's the boundary Union
wow that's cool really are you okay
nothing is going on you're amongst
friends now if you've been holed up here
waiting for a Facebook to settle oh all
I'm saying is time and money well spent
shut up Joey
too busy to call Jen we have been
worried about you should have gone on
the wachowskis in here yeah you never
know by the end of the episode
just enough left for me
champagne we'd love something we'd love
some too oh what only yes thank you
don't be a judgmental prick it's great
to finally meet you I mean we're huge
fans oh we want to get into show
business too
I don't know this woman is it is there I
guess Meg Tilly is is a real person yeah
it's like it's familiar in the back of
my mind
everyone always assumed I was older
because I got famous way before she did
you know I of course I did receive my
Oscar nomination 10 years before she did
so
but who's couch
oh Jen you look stunning thank you what
are you doing you're supposed to be
downstairs
you've been dodging me for 24 years
because clearly I did something to
offend you and Jen I miss you now I
forgive you
for for what that's what I wanted to
know what he has to pass
you know ever since you did that stupid
Chucky movie it's like you that's when
you stop talking to him the Chucky movie
was a big hit now um if you'll excuse me
I I I'm I'm just it's like a Louis CK
Dane Cook thing play on something real
wrong that is a character I played once
uh are you a fan of you no hell no no I
cheated when Tony destroyed your Guido
ass your head in that bag
spoilers yep
you should have watched it John screw it
now I can never watch it a little easy
on the stereotyping not all of us are
gangsters some of us a dress Cactus okay
Ralphie
you gamble
[Laughter]
not my ethnicity I draw from it's my
natural rage at morons like you they're
here
what about you Gina oh please do not
call me yep
um yeah I'm on a reality show was it a
reality show it was Hardcore reality
Laguna Beach last summer
I beg your pardon sir I swear to God if
I knew you were famous I would have
called you back
Glenn and I are both non-binary that's
good
go by they them yeah but they them have
always been plural Strunk on white the
Holy Bible of the English language
dictates that once you drag yourself
into the 21st century ass walk are they
all going to kill him tonight everyone
if I wasn't so desperate for help I'd
kill you myself I just put up some
cameras because I have nosy teenagers
and I can't take any chances but what
are you hiding in there anyway my
girlfriend
foreign
that is true hooray for Hollywood
you're gonna die by that bottle bro
oh my God
[Music]
oh my God Nico escaped
you know how the twins love them
wait this is is a murder mystery party
exactly Gina you know I love that
not really
that guy is no actor he's solid oak I
can see his eyes moving from here
snake
what is so important about that room
yeah it looks like Rapunzel's bedroom or
something I am going to be asking all
the questions
he come
how did Nikka Escape she running around
on stumps
oh she got help Andy
Eddie Caputo back from the grave I was
trying to make out the shape of that guy
yeah he seems a little lanky to be Andy
that
[Music]
that ball in here together
that was brilliant that was brilliant
Gina maybe you should lay out the
champagne a little bit Auntie Gino what
about this
Joey it must have killed the post-utan
self-defense that's good really good all
crimes are almost always about money
you're just rehashing your Housewives
bit from season 11. it was not a bit hey
hey
how about this
face again
but all of you had multiple motives
especially when the victim refused to
honor my kids pronouns who would commit
murder over pronoun maybe Glenn or
Glenda
um yeah
still an emergency I have to go put out
some fires
I'm gonna get yourself killed Meg I
could see it coming no okay well I mean
you're sleeping with someone because you
ghosted me no and you could tell me no
Gina Gina
there's O'Neill
can I tell you a secret here we go oh
goodness Gina
I love that they're redoings
magical
are you there
yeah
totally down for it if you let me watch
oh my God put your pants on Joey
I swear I didn't kill him he was dead
when I came down to get you
I think kahoots with whoever
dang
it's the only part of the house or
stupid app doesn't know about
she never knew about this room
me and Glenda found it when we were nine
pillow fort room I want to see what
she's hiding in that room
I didn't think you had it in you
you both got a little of that Killer
Instinct
where did you get those Auntie Gina gave
them to me
I have no idea what's in there
let's get ready to kill it
I think we should get out of here
grow a bear
get out of here there's an amputated
woman there oh God you would help me are
you better plan the whole time how do
you know who we are your mother is a
psychotic murderer I think she's in love
with me and she chopped off all my lips
and she's got me trapped in here for a
year I'm sorry I'm so lesbian
laughs
before I can just Waltz on out here I
need a safe place to go where your
mother is gonna hunt me down gag me and
get out of here don't tell her you found
me I have a plan you'll help me of
course we'll help you
I'll distract mom Glenda looks so
interested
don't don't leave you enough
I forgot this
here he comes what the hell is wrong
with you
oh does it start bringing back her
her nightmares probably I'm your dad
I wanted to stay but your mom drove me
away and lied to you about it this is
all [ __ ] so when you're ready to get
revenge on your mom for keeping us apart
come back I got a plan [ __ ] face
I always meant that affectionately
oh foreign
creepy ass Brad Dourif produced such a
beautiful daughter
[Laughter]
you know it skips a generation
you're a good kid Glenn
definitely not like your parents
do you know my Dad too
yikes
yeah
he has crazy as my mom is
a little bit
foreign
ever cool
[Music]
it was him
Wheeling
her
I guess so I mean take it back it oh my
goodness
you ready to kill your mom [ __ ] face
what did you just say to me [ __ ]
oh I'm not Nico
I say it looked more like Glenda in the
window then
oh Chucky why don't you just die already
[Laughter]
you first
take the shot Meg
jump in front of it yes
Jackie please we can still work things
out
Kara you already broke my heart Jackie
okay the head it is
she supposed to be the murderer because
we haven't met her it's not totally fair
I'm almost Gonna Miss You Tiff
[Music]
Glenn
yeah
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
are you following this are you falling
Put Your Hooks into her
[Music]
oh Nika that was your chance although
you would have looked like a straight up
murderer and gone to jail if you had
done that holy crap yeah
mom needs help we all do
just ask her who's Tiffany Valentine
[Music]
[Laughter]
Chucky's Agatha Christie story
oh my God
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn I know it is
[Music]
Kyle yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
so by extension
and he would be one would imagine maybe
I'm still 50 50.
now let's roll the
roll the just just enough
flipping me
yes we'd love some we love some too
oh Jen you look stunning thank you
there's my girl you know it what it had
to be a killer reawakened who took the
bullets out of the gun
I knew she was seeing someone else it's
not what you think
really Joey no pants ha ha
do
you love her
or not
I love her
wrong answer
[Music]
that's awesome
the networks concerned fans might have
missed seeing yours truly in action
plus they've probably missed hearing my
10 a lot of death bombs wait they only
give you 10 f-bombs per episode
the contract roll the tape
I want Chucky to kill me isn't that a
dream
it's a dream I don't I don't want a
starring role I don't want to lead I
just want to be
brutally murdered by Chucky
dreams do come true
let's do this
let's do this
say the words transfer Soul thank you
very much this concludes our very
special episode of check
tune in again next week as I continue to
torture those [ __ ] kids
sweet dreams
foreign
well done
well done what did you think I was uh
delighted by that entire experience I
love an episode that
diverts from the main plot and focuses
in on yeah a side character but a very
important side character at that and
then has on top of that just the carte
blanche and the freedom to go
off-roading and to yeah bring in some
other it's like we're already here
having Jennifer Tilly be Jennifer Tilly
but not Jennifer Tilly and using
Jennifer Tilly's life as an instrument
so now you know bringing in actual other
people from some of her most I mean from
Brown which is one of her most iconic
movies and then also bringing in her
sister and all this other stuff like I I
just loved the layers on layers of like
this seemed like a really fun episode to
conceive of and write and especially as
a reintroduction for you know the new
Glenn and Glenda you know grown up to
the point that they have I thought it
was a nice choice to then really make
the episode Special to Showcase them
without necessarily having to do like a
deep dive into here's where they've been
all this time you know you you get a a
fascinating present day diversion with
this whole weird meta murder mystery but
also it seems like a nice fitting
reintroduction to Glenn and Glenda
because they do have that element of
like there is the Killer Instinct and
now that they've been separated you know
you can see how it affects the both of
them and now clearly Glenn duh is the
one with you know the more Killer
Instinct and Glenn is the more
sympathetic of the two and uh and yeah
but it still leaves some level of maybe
a mystery as to you know if that lurks
within Glenn as well so uh yeah I was
delighted by this what did you think
uh
yeah uh I mean I enjoyed it I thought it
was fun uh I didn't I don't think I
think you enjoyed it a lot more than I
did it's I'm kind of in The Divide here
for it I I think the I mean we haven't
seen bound I don't think really I don't
know so it was really quick for you with
all a lot of this click for you uh I
mean I I can't I don't want to say it
wouldn't because I know that even if you
haven't seen it I'm sure a lot of this
would if there was something kind of
fascinating to me about kind of the The
Whimsy of it it took a little bit of
time for me to really
just it's like
I enjoyed it I don't prefer this style
over what the show generally is like if
that makes sense like I I enjoyed it but
uh I like something when it actually is
a little bit
a little scary yeah that's that's fair a
little suspenseful a little bit horror
based and this was uh it didn't go like
full-on like seed of I mean it could
really went there like the seat of
Chucky Madness like it really it really
uh it was more in tune with that yeah I
mean I enjoyed it overall I think
Jennifer Tilly really holds it down here
and like she is so hilarious and
like she's so it's really I think it's
easy to overlook her and when she's so
good she's she she is like brilliant in
this role in every uncomfortable
situation that she's put in and I enjoy
Glenn and Glenda I like I like the way
they they drew that line and like you
know you always have Chucky influencing
people and then to bring it out of his
own daughter this is like her she seems
so Disturbed when you're wondering what
path is really going to go down
so yeah I did hear Kyle would return uh
or I heard I heard Kyle would be back in
this season so
yeah it was kind of I wish I didn't hear
that you heard what did you hear you're
about Catholic [ __ ] that's what you
heard I heard yeah that there would be a
a heavy religious angle of some kind
Kathleen if you went to Catholic school
or you grew up Catholic this will
resonate with you yeah yeah
uh but no I actually we didn't what do
we leave offensions I didn't re-watch
the first season what would we leave off
with Kyle
uh isn't there like a fake out of
something fake out death right yeah
yeah yeah yeah because I I I was sort of
like thinking that I guess I hadn't
thought of her returning because of that
no but if you don't see it happen Yeah
Yeah well yeah which is why we're all
sitting here going where's Andy when's
he coming yeah yeah totally
but uh no I get you I mean like it's not
what I would want the whole season to
turn into I like it because it's a
one-off episode but I also would agree
that yeah like it's what the suspense of
the episode ultimately comes down to is
you know we know someone's going to open
the door and find Nika and the question
is has a Chucky broken in or is it you
know Glenn or Glenda who is responsible
for this and I I did I like too that you
have the red herring that is Joey pants
you know turning up dead and that being
completely unrelated
um but yeah it's not the most if if you
like the slasher elements of Chucky this
is probably not one of the more
satisfying episodes because it's you
know not playing on
on that and it's it's yeah it's way more
down the Hollywood
uh kookiness
uh rabbit hole that Chucky does
obviously Encompass but isn't uh it
isn't a flavor of the most beloved era
of Chucky either so it's very Seed of
Chucky yeah yeah it's very much so
which I think is appropriate to honor
when you're doing your Glenn and Glenda
episode 100. so there's the intent
behind it like don't get me wrong I did
I I guess I'm not
so people I feel like it's so easy for
things to be received in a very black
and white way of thinking I'm just not
super enthusiastic about this enamored
yeah even though I liked it even though
I enjoyed it uh you know generally my
enthusiasm is much higher for an episode
of Chucky and to me I'm like no I was
really impressed with it I'm glad that
you know getting the reunion back here
they really had fun messing with the
alter ego personalities of putting them
on screen and letting them like
literally doing something different like
um uh with like would bring Gina back
you know at first
I felt like she was just there you know
it seemed like she was just there doing
nothing but then when the murder mystery
thing kicked in
I was like oh they're they're having a
lot of fun with her yeah now she's doing
a lot of really fun things and then I
felt it was really rewarding yeah uh Joe
of course you know like they really let
him do weird [ __ ] I loved it yeah oh my
God yeah so they let him do agree so I
thought it's it it's really easy to do
something like this and then just have
them not like do much so to have them
actually
have some real fun with their characters
and let them go down some type of
Macabre path was really enjoyable and
it's like Chucky's version of an Agatha
Christie story so I I get what they were
going for and yeah it was it was overall
enjoyable and there's just something
about the particular flavor that in the
first half of it was there's something I
think it was the energy of the episode
just wasn't quite clicking with me
that's sort of the momentum of it
um I think the epilogue is great in
terms of rap I mean I kind of wish we
could have figured it out together as an
audience as opposed to just Chucky
unveiling everything because I'm like ah
come on a little bit more if you're
doing like a murder mystery thing let's
figure it out together let's have the
reveals happen and I would have enjoyed
seeing that but what they supplemented
it with when you're doing your super
meta episode playing on something that
I'm assuming is a real life thing that
happened with the wrestler oh that
podcast bit yeah yeah I'm assuming
that's very that that's a real flip and
they honor that when you're doing your
meta episode to bring that into the fold
at the very end
uh I think is very enjoyable so that's
what I mean is like even though I'm not
familiar with who this wrestler is I
don't follow this I have this is the
first time ever hearing this podcast
clip it still made it a very weirdly
like really enjoyable ending and yeah I
I think overall it's uh it's fun to me I
could see why people would really like
this episode so I wouldn't dog on it
because I could see what people were
like and I like the movie Bound a lot
yeah it is it's all like the visual
references and then the the parodies of
those moments well and do we do we have
credits because I was sitting here
wondering too the whole time like I
really like the the actor or actors who
play Glenn and Glenda and and the same
person I I was wondering that I was like
is this a split screen are they doing
yeah like the shot when they're looking
at each other towards the end look like
a split screen I could and I was like
are their noses slightly different I
can't tell but I I think uh whoever the
actor or actors is I I like them quite a
lot both of they uh because both of them
uh because they do feel cut of the same
cloth they do feel akin to the character
as seen in the previous movies but also
you know I thought the performance on
both ends was actually like quality like
you know good nuance and good you know
I don't know not that I would have
expected less but uh you know I I yeah I
thought they did a really good job
I think it's just one actor
wow
well done
well done and and two and and just like
did a lot of framing where it looked
like they would be split yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure there were times where it
I didn't feel like they were in the same
room yeah no totally in the way the dot
and the in the way when sometimes the
back and forth would go yeah especially
amongst other people it just didn't
there was something that felt a little
off sure like it didn't feel like there
was a
chemistry between them all but in the
final scene it did in the in the final
scene it definitely did but I did notice
there was always usually something
dividing them yeah in frame until that
one shot until at the very end when they
when they go their separate paths then I
was like okay yeah this is definitely
has to be like the same time because
it's tricky because this seems like an
episode that has a lot of improv and a
lot of like the actors probably having
fun and figuring out you know the bits
and stuff and so I would imagine that
yeah then doing a technique like this
probably is the the the the the hardest
part to make coalesce in an environment
like that which I mean is impressive for
the amount that they were able to do it
but I also agree there are times where
I'm sitting there going wait a minute
though is this a split screen or or what
you know well I I did appreciate with
the transgender talk though to say the
least that they they actually went into
it because while
um you know Cedar Chucky has
it's apparent that it's it's there uh
but the comment it's it's such a like
such a wackadoodle movie and it's and
and a lot of it is also like this is is
Glenn and Glenn are they gonna kill and
it's not really about that with these
characters like they really made it
about and they they actually explored
identity yeah with them here and I think
to bring them back in a in a day and age
where it is a it is a big discussion
they managed to do it without making it
all about that yeah you know yeah like
they have the commentary and they they
go more into the the identity discussion
without it
without it taking away or losing a
momentum about the episode you know yeah
it's well within the boundaries of of
how the Chucky franchise has
incorporated that conversation up until
now and the way the conversation has
grown with you know the public discourse
and so yeah here I thought it was well
Incorporated and I just really like the
way they realize Glenn and Glenda as
you know I liked the just their I don't
know each is aesthetic and and the way
that they you know physically realize
these characters as you know these two
you know non-binary fluid characters
they feel very real well I think I don't
know how to pronounce this person's name
Lachlan Watson Boogie don't know Lachlan
wants its pronouns
uh however I will proceed to talk about
lachlaw
Lachlan Watson I guess they is the
safest they will be the safest uh I
think they did a a really even though I
would become aware because it's really
just an issue of like what Clips you
chose to put them together in and you
know so that's I'm not it to me it's not
a
okay I'm not criticizing their
performance as I think they actually did
a really great job as both these
characters I thought they were excellent
and and to really make them feel like
completely different people with I think
the smart choice too sure you know where
that I think there's a bit of uh there's
a bit of a weird rules and confusion I I
personally felt by the NFC to Chucky
sure yeah especially when they became
real life yeah uh but to do it in this
approach I thought Lachlan Watson did a
really great job with both characters
feeling distinct that if I didn't if I
personally wasn't noticing like I could
see the split in in the green screening
or whatever though I don't know the
proper term would be for it but whenever
I could see it if I didn't see it I
would have assumed they were two
completely different actors yeah totally
and I and I think they do nicely within
Universe to make them similar enough
that yeah these are obviously twins of
some kind but they seem different enough
to sell I think it does kind of clarify
or help Claire verify some of those
personality aspects that aren't as clear
in seat of Chucky that now you know you
the question mark to me is does Glenn
have any sort of Killer Instinct within
because Glenn obviously is the one who
is not okay with murdering people and
Glenda has that and that's in line with
Seed of Chucky but you know I think part
of what they'll probably play with is
the fact that they are such both a blend
of their parents and you know one leans
heavily more to one side than the other
but they are both cut of that cloth
um but yeah yeah just as two distinct
characters who need to be similar enough
but not the same I thought yeah it was a
nicely handled uh dual performance yeah
yeah yeah
I mean take the step out of your Rhythm
here John oh
what happened I feel like my lack of
enthusiasm dragged the energy down no
I'm I'm just happy to have watched
another Chucky man I love this show so
much it's so easy to and I'm happy to be
able to discuss it uh even on this on
this wavelength even if you weren't
isn't chuffed on it as I was I'm happy
to have the discussion I just hate the
black and white feedback that happens
sometimes when you say [ __ ] like that
I'm like no I liked it but everyone's
doing it yeah
every time so I gotta say it like I just
know how this goes well that is like
Jesus I just I'm just not in the even
though I'm not dealing with it right now
in this moment it's just the thought of
dealing with it was like I don't wanna
like weirdly put my mood down a weird
path
that's that's the risk you run when you
do an episode like this and I can I can
uh maybe can't name one off the top of
my head but I feel like you know
whenever somebody brings up a one-off
distinct sort of Quest episodes
yeah but I feel like you know it's an
easy one to to be like oh maybe that
wasn't wasn't so much for me for XXX
reason you know because yeah like it is
a Gamble and it is a a Twist and a turn
and it is a bit of a risk so it's like
yeah it's not gonna be a hundred percent
for everybody and I do agree as much as
I enjoyed and had fun with this I do
maybe wish that because they were going
for Agatha Christie and because they
were doing so much in the form of
emulating she even named checks you know
it was like BBC detective you know
theater shows uh you do
uh you know academically crave then a
more satisfying actual mystery that yeah
we could have like I like the met a bit
of like well how are we supposed to like
these are there are people involved that
we weren't even aware of so we can't
really piece it together and like it's
funny that they point that out but also
you're like man if this had been like a
really windy this had also been like a
Knives Out Chucky mystery uh you know
that would have been that much more
satisfying because I've seen a lot of
shows where they decide to do their
Agatha Christie episode so I was I was
hoping a little bit more for that punch
where you got like dysfunctional Reunion
yeah and then oh my God someone dies and
maybe they're all capable of it instead
of being like most of these people
didn't do it yeah yeah
yeah I think
um I I think we'll probably would have
helped us add a tad bit more of a real
pulse to it as if Tiffany was instantly
like
who's working with Nika or who's working
who knows about this and wanted to let
her out instead of being so like I can't
say anything about it yeah yeah
who killed the butler you know yeah like
really who like is someone in on this
yeah yeah they just would have added a
different type of scope
uh two at all
wow it doesn't really matter it's fun
it's a fun episode and that's all they
set out to really do here is just do
something that was unique and fun and I
thought overall they delivered and I
think um
Anika is is like she's she's so good
that's so good it doesn't feel like
nepotism at all like you know what I
mean like it feels like she's just
perfectly she's day one you know since
she's been great like she's so good and
it doesn't feel like you just got it
because you're the daughter of Brad
Dourif like she is so good well I feel
like there may be don't quote me I feel
like there may be some kind of aspect to
the story of like you know oh she maybe
auditioned for like a smaller role or
something and they should they were like
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait you're you're
so good that you know we're gonna
basically make you the lead of this and
then make you you know part of it so
it's like you know I guess it would be
easy to do that nepotism but at the same
time it seemed like it was actually like
no no no you deserve these this role
basically and well it's like only Brad
Dourif can do Chucky yeah and but when
she does Chucky it's very believable
sure it doesn't feel like she's
impersonating Chucky no yeah and she was
like she's in there she is being Chucky
in that moment yeah and it's a it's a
difficult task to put upon someone sure
and then to throw these physical
handicaps in her that when she's
switching between whatever ever
emotional state
like if there's anything I really
admired about this episode it was the
acting of a lot of people yeah more than
the writing and directing it was really
the acting of these care of everyone
that I thought was really solid like
Jennifer Tilly impressed to be this far
down the line in in the Chucky franchise
and then to do something like this where
I'm like wow I didn't even check in with
Chucky until the only in the book ends
yeah and you are just holding this whole
episode down this is your showcase you
are so good in this episode she's so
funny and you can feel the different
types of uh like racing thoughts going
through her the entire time while she
tries to put up a certain display and
then deal with her own ego
simultaneously like it it was done she
was she was excellent and and
um Fiona dorif I thought was so
impressive too you know like that the
desperation on things and the and every
little scene that she had of when she's
talking with Glenn and the way of
handling the information being
communicated was so good it was so well
realized and like she's so good at
being scared and desperate and and
frightened and then being frightening
like she's she's so good at it all yeah
uh and and apparently has like legit
wheelchair skills from a prior role
she'd played yeah which you know were
incorporated into the movies but here I
was like damn like you're really
throwing down on that thing and now she
got her new arms so that's that's the
thing she got a prosthetic arms
which I guess Glenn or Glenda must have
brought yeah
um but yeah no the absolutely this is a
a lovely showcase for them and a nice
reminder of Meg Tilly's existence
because I feel like I've had my mind
blown by that before like I feel like
I've seen her in things and then
eventually someone would be like yeah
Meg Tilly it's Jennifer Tilly's sister
and I'm like what I have no idea who he
is yeah yeah I've I I know I've seen
movies that she's been in and I've
probably been told but it's also one of
those things where yeah I haven't
I haven't thought of
feel bad for saying it because she's got
a pretty you know long career
um she's in The Big Chill there you go
psycho two some horror cred I never saw
a psycho too body snatcher um but no I'm
not uh The Big Chill like let's assuming
I was like a little boy but being forced
to watch it with my dad then you should
have remembered
at all I don't remember that movie yeah
um but apparently she's the younger one
issue really that's what they said
and I guess I would take that as truth
but you never know she was born in 1960
let's do this I don't know about that
really
I mean I want something
yeah man it's just a number 1960 1958
wow Jennifer Jennifer till he's two
years old boy
I am so shocked by this I thought
Jennifer Tilly would be like 40 or
something 45. he looks like she's oh my
God not to be that guy but she does look
incredible for her age and she seems
maybe she's had like botox or what I
mean like Gina
yeah or Gerson I would say I've said
Gershon my whole life you're I don't
know I've heard it both ways
um like she looks like she's had some
work done Gina Gershwin yes yes not bad
work but work yeah yeah it's it's like
it's obviously
uh it's not like men do it too uh like
close and I always pointing out when men
do it too all right I'm just saying
all right fair game
let's get Mickey
yeah Gina Gershon um yeah it was
noticeable I mean maybe Jennifer Tilly
has but it doesn't look that way like
she looks the same to me because she
always has she's always looked the same
yeah she looks it looks like she's
actually just aged gracefully to me
versus like you've had work done so
that's surprising I mean maybe she has
damn obviously I am so shocked to learn
that she's maybe she's just had subtle
subtle and very little work I don't know
she's like what 64. I guess so my God
it's crazy
yeah okay let me do the math here yeah
yeah it's got to be no no no no no
64. yeah because 2018 would be
60. yeah okay yeah wow
shocking
dude whatever you're doing Jen it's it's
great we need the secrets
it's half asian I guess you know maybe
maybe that helps is she half asian I
believe so yeah yeah
it usually does help
the Fountain of Youth is just being are
they like actual full are they half
sisters
I think they don't look alike to me they
I would never have said their I can I
can see it when I'm told but if I was to
just if they were side by side and I
wasn't thinking about it and wasn't
aware I don't know if I would actually
pick it up or not
whatever all right all right guys we're
done thanks for being here we'll talk to
you soon
[Music]